we're here with radoslaviadinak the
president of the Polish Chess Federation
rather Salam first of all welcome back
to the show tell us a bit about this uh
surge of popularity in Polish uh chess
how did you see this from the inside
well uh trust in Poland we're always
very popular I remember
times in our history before the war do
you interest olympiading Wars of 1935
when every ticket was sold out it was
about 5 000 tickets so this is no
surprise to me that we see crowds of
people here in the theater watching the
games chess is extremely popular in
Poland we estimate we have millions of
people playing chess but in the
Federation there is 125
000 registered players and I think a
very important is to impact the Young
Generation do you see the numbers of
young people picking up chess yes the
numbers are growing and there are uh
giant I believe the main reason is
unchart of the Superstar world-class
Superstar and all these young uh young
Juniors they want to
um to be like him and this is this is
very very well some people never had
after the war we we didn't have such a
player this is a great impact and we
have exactly 55 000 registered juniors
in the Federation and he's not the only
one uh radoslav voitage is an incredible
example as well and what a better way to
open up the tournament than to defeat
the world champion in the Polish opening
how did you leave that moment
I was watching the game but I think that
Magnus went too far he wanted probably
to make a show and not a disrespect
maybe but somehow he
he might have believed that rather is
maybe not the best player in the world
so he can play polish opening and and
but I was very
I was how to say it's a gamble right
yeah
europocal poker player as well former
poker yes a former poker player when I
became president of the Federation I
stopped playing poker professionally I
played in European Poker Tour 15 years
ago yeah I see Magnus cousins playing in
Monte was playing in Monte Carlo uh well
I like it very much I published it on my
chess my my fan page of my present of
the preparation of my own well I think
he's doing a very good thing what is
there's a very um for me it is very
important that such a superstar like
Magnus also plays poker like me in the
western where this is normal but
sometimes in Poland not the government
is not so kidney with legalizing the
gambling but yeah I don't think maybe as
you know in Poland talking about poker
it's uh no it's not like in the United
States with the richest normal but
Poland it is right but we see a lot of
uh incredible chess tournaments and not
only this one you guys organize the
world rapid and Blitz here not so long
ago what are the plans for the future
well the plans we are organizing a woman
Team Championship world team
championship women in September really
because 5 to 12 of September and we are
expecting the best
teams from the world to be there and I I
already know this will be another great
tournament in Poland after this
important award Blitz and Rapid in
National Stadium in 2021 now there will
be also a woman a team championship but
also we organize disabled World
Championship disabled in September and
also seniors European seniors in
in sorry in August and in July so there
are a lot of
International tournaments chess in
Poland in every month runs love you have
a lot of work ahead of yourself we'll
let you go back to the games enjoy the
games thank you very much for all your
support okay